la parole est à notre collègue jean
claude lenoir pour le groupe l'est
républicain et pour deux minutes
monsieur le président mes chers
collègues chacun le sait notre
agriculture l'élevage français
connaissent depuis des mois une crise
sans précédent crise qui menace des
dizaines de milliers d'emplois ainsi que
nos territoires ruraux le gouvernement
juillet dernier a pris un certain nombre
de mesures conjoncturelles pour soulager
la trésorerie des exploitations
le sénat quant à lui à l'initiative de
son président travaille sans relâche en
liaison avec la profession pour apporter
des réponses structurelles à ce secteur
d'activité et pour offrir des
perspectives au monde agricole c'est
ainsi que nous avons en décembre dernier
adopté à une large majorité une
proposition de loi dans l'objet est de
replacer la compétitivité au coeur de la
politique agricole
ce texte viendra en discussion le 4
février prochain l'assemblée nationale
devrait savoir monsieur me de
l'agriculture si vous allez soutenir
cette proposition de loi devant les
députés pour vont répandre la parole est
à mme suspects le foll les listes de
l'agriculture de l'agroalimentaire le
forez porte-parole du gouvernement pour
2009 et la parole ce plaisir monsieur
sénateur vous avez évoqué la proposition
de loi que nous avons débattu ici au
sénat sur votre proposition qui
comportait un certain nombre de mesures
mais par rapport à la crise de l'élevage
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui je
voudrais rappeler que cette crise est
d'abord une crise de marché à l'échelle
européenne et à l'échelle mondiale que
ça soit sur la question du lait je
voudrais leur rappeler quand même où le
fait que nous soyons et c'est aussi un
atout un grand pays exportateur de l'est
nous sommes dépendants des évolutions
des prix sur des marchés qui sont bien
loin même du marché européen puisque il
s'agit du marché asiatique que cette
crise laitière a eu des conséquences
aussi sur la filière bovine puisque les
restructurations qui sont engagées dans
un certain nombre de pays ont fait que
les abattages de vaches de réformes
laitières sont venues peser sur le
marché de la viande bovine et que sur la
viande porcine filière extrêmement
touchée aujourd'hui
c'est une situation de marché qui dure
depuis plus de 8 10 ans où on a perdu de
la compétitivité et ce débat que nous
avons eu avec des propositions que vous
avez fait auquel je voudrais rappeler
que le pack de responsabilité dans la
totalité qui concerne à la fois
l'agriculture et l'agroalimentaire c'est
l'équivalent l'équivalent du budget
d'agriculture le budget de l'agriculture
aujourd'hui c'est 4 2 milliards d'euros
la totalité du pack de responsabilité
agricoles et agroalimentaires en 2016 ça
sera 4,3 milliards d'euros
cette question de la compétitivité et
cet engagement qui a été pris et qui va
se poursuivre d'ailleurs dans le plan
qui a été présenté par le président de
la république qui a été salué par les
organisations professionnelles en partie
des coopératives sur le fait qu'on
allait passer le cic eux sur la baisse
des charges sociales
c'est un engagement qui a été pris qui
doit se poursuivre qui doit s'organiser
vous avez fait des propositions elles
doivent compléter un dispositif qui doit
redonner par l'organisation des filières
agricoles et de l'élevage la capacité à
notre élevage et à ne construire en
terre d'être à nouveau une grande
agriculture en europe
pour vous répondre en réplique le
président lenoir ministre une logorrhée
n'est pas la meilleure réponse à une
question précise
au moment où je parle les éleveurs
connaissent une vraie détresse est un
vrai désarroi sur nos territoires
chacun ici quel que soit le banc qu'il
occupe peu en répondrez en témoigner
aujourd'hui on voit les prix sont en
train de dégringoler
que ce soit pour le porc la viande ou
pour le lait
le premier semestre est annoncé comme
particulièrement difficile
or nous avons proposé une série de
mesures qui permettent de rétablir une
relation juste équilibrée entre les
acteurs de la filière agricole qui
consiste également à aider au
financement nécessaire des
investissements et à assurer le
financement de la gestion des risques
des aléas notamment aujourd'hui
sanitaire avec la grippe aviaire et
d'autres calamités qui s'abattent sur
nos élevages et enfin pour alléger les
charges qu'elles soient fiscales
sociales ou administrative nous avons
aussi eu président entendu la réponse du
porte-parole du gouvernement
nous attendons une réponse du ministre
des agriculteurs merci